well as our president welcomes his
French counterpart let's not forget how
the media portrays Trump's harmful
foreign policy Republicans really have a
responsibility to talk about the
imminent threat that they know because
they've seen behind the scenes that this
man poses to the safety and the security
of the United States of America I've
asked Twitter spokesmen does this
violate Twitter's Terms of Service
making this kind of threat toward North
Korea on the world stage this president
is humiliating America no question well
that didn't age well so does the
president of France agree with them we
have a lot of work to be done together
but I'm very very very pleased because
whatever the context could be this
relationship is stronger than the evens
and on top of it we have done an
excellent personal relationship so I
want to thank you for that hmm our poor
media the sophisticated European adores
our president and why should me he is
adorable it's a great honor great honor
to be here but we do have a very special
relationship
in fact I'll get that little piece of
dandruff oh we have to make them perfect
he is perfect oh my god some would break
out the therapy llamas because every
single narrative the media uses the
slime Trump seems to flunk the reality
test it's a difference in between Trump
and Obama Obama was beloved by our media
but our global adversaries saw him as a
mark Trump is despised by the media but
effective on the world stage let's
review that world stage shall we well
Isis is more than handled for now North
Korea bold moves by Trump may create an
historic thaw Syria he drew red lines
and then he reforged them
he made that historic visit to the homes
of each major religion he embraced the
new Saudi leader a key ally he
recognized Jerusalem as Israel's capital
and behind it all he's rebuilding our
military telling the world that his
priorities are that and it ain't the
vanishing polar bears in shorts Oh
was the substitute teacher you could
spin in six different directions Trump
is the scary football coach who runs
detention here's what he said about Iran
if Iran threatens us in any way they
will pay a price like few countries have
ever paid Wow
there's a pattern here when Trump enters
the equation an actual reset takes place
a reset that creates chaos but it's
chaos by design as any negotiator knows
you can't play an adversary that you
can't figure out trump's greatest asset
unpredictability and he knows it it's
only our media who hasn't figured that
out yet they're still stuck on trump's
spelling errors so peed on a scale of 1
to nothing to 10 everything it's Donald
Trump the greatest president that has
ever lived
can I buy an 11 your you nailed it I'll
give you your kudos thank you as I know
you appreciate I enjoy a good Kudo
the unpredictability the key when you're
strong and you have competence
confidence and you believe in American
power then then people your adversaries
are fear you and your allies respect you
and in some ways what what President
Trump has done is they lay up in foreign
policy he decided to stand by our
traditional allies right and stand up to
the enemies of the free world yeah
whether it's China on trade whether it's
North Korea whether it's dictators
whether it's Iran I think he'll scrap
the Iran deal in spite of Emmanuel
macron attempt to do otherwise
yeah he's we haven't needed the French
since I think 1775 but it's nice to have
yeah why are you resting while you were
saying in the green room to me earlier I
have to admit Donald Trump is the
greatest president that ever lived
Baker's 30 niz the bad luck I am struck
by what you're saying because when I
look I think about foreign policy and I
think to myself wait a second this is
the guy you say enforced a red line of
course he was saying we should get out
of sea right and then you had
Republicans saying oh no you better
fakers you don't want to start any
trouble you need a forest there and they
mostly enforces a red line and of course
then you have people saying well this
was pretty ineffective he didn't do much
here so what is exactly the strategy we
don't have a strategy and then I think
to myself well let me listen to Greg
Greg is saying this guy is a great
foreign policy leader so I think to
myself oh that must mean that McCrone
has come across the ocean and he's
saying Oh mr. president thank you but in
fact he's saying you're wrong on the
Iran deal he's saying you're wrong right
trade he's saying I long on Syria and
then Angela Merkel is coming at the end
of the week and she's going to oh is she
going to Pat president Trump no she's
gonna enforce what McCrone has said to
trump about disagreements but the thing
that's interesting about President Trump
when he has these meetings whether it's
with adversaries or with us whether it's
with allies is he always focuses on the
agreement first and as you've seen him
come through the first year of his
presidency he is emboldened the allies
and he's kind of distance themselves
from the people who aren't necessarily
in our interest turkey is one of those
examples when it comes to Syria he
addressed that today he talked about the
Iran deal I talked with a serious
strategy being look we want to get out
eventually but we have to have a plan
because we don't want the Mediterranean
as he said to be a free-for-all for the
Iranians and we're controlling that
territory now when it comes to the Iran
deal I also believe based on the
president's rhetoric in the past few
months and also today he said it was
built on decaying foundation and has
continued to decay that the language is
telling us he's going to scrap it but
there the agreement is not necessary
crema isn't necessarily the Iran deal is
bad there's agreement on that there's
just disagreement about how to fix it
what's plan B and whether you can fix it
yeah so they're gonna tag-team him a
little bit Europeans all right so you
had somebody that he has a very good
relationship with interpersonally
there's a lot of charm and warmth then
they seem to get along again
besides the dandruff comet well with one
another somebody when you do that
they're calling out the guy for having
gained a little bit yeah but you know
anyway
like that they have a glass of wine
later and they forget all about it so
what's gonna happen is now Merkel has a
much more contentious relationship she's
been quite critical of the president but
she's going to have to roll that back a
little bit in terms of trying to get
some diplomacy because there are things
that the two of them want they want to
be able to have him reconsider their on
nuclear agreement and he wants them to
get involved and go along with what he
wants to do as it relates to Syria and
Iran in terms of that you know
geopolitical area that is strife with
problems in in the Middle East so in
terms of that he's already got in his
head some kind of negotiating chip of
they're gonna have to play ball they can
actually respectful she's gonna have to
stop with a the you know incessant
criticism because guess what she's no
longer the Iron Lady I think that she
was she has been tremendously weakened
politically across Europe with the
problems that she's had there and in
terms of the elections etc so see what
happens the end of the week I would
argue too that the president has
actually taken a little bit of pressure
off of the Europeans by calling on the
Arab nations around around Iran who are
very concerned about them restarting
their nuclear programs they've
threatened to do he has said this is
your responsibility in your region which
allows the Europeans to take a step back
and go okay this is in our interest to
be involved here but the people who
really need to make sure the rules are
being followed are the people in the
neighborhood and that is the Arab nation
he's also reasserted the real power
relationship between US and the European
nations I mean Barack Obama was
deferential to these countries didn't
have no business we were inferior yeah
we were equal to them we were not you
know we were all exceptional nations to
him but you know you look at France
they've gutted their military to pay for
their welfare state they've opened their
borders they don't demand a
symbolization they've got terrorism
problem they've got demographic problems
they aren't the world power they used to
be sure they own a seat on the Security
Council that's thanks to us in the UN
that whole global system is largely
irrelevant he's sort of just padding you
know wiping off the dandruff at him on
the shoulders in France they call it
shoulder snow just because Trump made
you laugh today well actually I was
hoping that I would get some of the lamb
I understand
lamb at the stand over so last night
lamb tonight I'm glad he's draining the
swamp of all these elitist you know it's
lamb elitist food damn lamb chops yes
you know at a state dinner was it for
150 not a big state they're in a tiny
state dinner I love it I next time you
know what Jesse's not here so you got
you need somebody in there what the
liberal quibbling the details oh yeah
going out to her spelling and his food
wait show you want one this is um I just
want to show you how special this
relationship is that everywhere leader
when they meet Trump they come away with
a special feeling take a look at this
thank you thank you
I like him a lot it's an honor to call
you my friend thank you
[Applause]
it's like it's a buddy comedy more like
well it could be 48 hours he's a weapon
the problem here the big problem is that
you have McCrone and the Europeans that
you guys I mean you sound like Don
Rumsfeld old Europe I mean but but I
mean Europe guess what as McCrone has
said the United States needs allies we
do we have allies and we they are our
principal allies right now especially in
the war against terror and so when you
look at McCrone you looking at a guy
who's a globalist Pete a bolus and Trump
is an isolationist and is that's why the
tariffs issue whatever crazy so he gets
along you should be celebrating the fact
that he can work in this fashion with
someone who perhaps is ideologically
different or disparate than him hold on
thank you no but actually one I hope
that I hope that Matt Khurana is able to
talk to him about the tariffs maybe the
tariffs is part of a bigger thing that
Trump is working on to get like
something that we're not seeing cuz I
hate tariffs and I hope that that that
changes but it seems to me that he
listened he listened to him about Syria
he listens it from the tariffs the
tariffs would affect Europe and
specifically haven't happened yet shall
we move on you guys she's in wine is
still gonna come in here don't worry all
right back